this is a 2d version of my 3d video
about phosphoglucose isomerase
if you have a VR headset I highly
recommend my 3d video there's a link in
the video description but if you're
ready let's experience this enzyme in 2d
you may see phosphoglucose isomerase
called a few names one of which is
glucose 6 phosphate isomerase but both
of these names contain the same
information in glycolysis the molecule
that acts as the substrate is glucose 6
phosphate or g6p and it undergoes an
isomerization reaction forming fructose
6-phosphate
which will call f6p isomerization
changes the arrangement of the covalent
bonds in a molecule but the chemical
formula of the isomers is the same delta
g for the isomerization reaction of G 6
P 2 F 6 P is negative 2.92 and at
cellular pH it's calculated to be a
positive 1 point 6 7 what this means is
that the isomerization reaction is
pretty close to equilibrium Delta G and
Delta G naught prime are both hovering
right around 0 therefore the reaction
performed by this enzyme is reversible
the relative concentrations of g6p and
f6p
in the cytoplasm of the cell will
determine whether the enzyme will
catalyze the forward or reverse reaction
so this enzyme is important in both the
glycolysis pathway which breaks down
glucose to produce energy and the
gluconeogenesis pathway which makes
glucose from non carbohydrate sources in
this video I'll refer to phosphoglucose
isomerase as PGI the active form of the
PGI enzyme is a dimer which means two
chains of the protein come together to
form the active enzyme because two
distinct polypeptide chains
come together this enzyme has quaternary
structure which not every protein has
let's color one chain white and one
chain magenta so we can see each clearly
in this cartoon representation or
rendering of the enzyme this dimer has a
lot of symmetry I want you to focus on
these beta sheets right here on the half
of the dimer that we've colored white
now I'm going to turn the protein 180
degrees notice this similar section of
beta sheet on the other side which is
composed mostly of the magenta chain
let's change our representation to
space-filling where each atom of every
amino acid in the protein is represented
by a sphere to show its surface I love
this rendering because it gives a clear
view of how the dimer is intertwined
it's like one chain of the enzyme is
giving the other a hug now let's switch
to the surface rendering of the protein
keeping our coloring the same each half
of the enzyme contains a fully
functional active site in this structure
the enzyme is bound to an inhibitor
shown in green sticks the inhibitor is
bound to both active sites and if we
zoom in a little bit more we can see
although this active site is mostly made
up of the side of the dimer we colored
white some of the magenta half of the
dimer is part of the active site too in
fact some of the amino acid residues
from the magenta side participate in the
chemical reaction on the white side so
dimerization is critical to enzyme
activity you may be wondering how the
dimer is actually held together in the
body the interactions are the same weak
interactions that hold substrates and
inhibitors in active sites like we saw
in my hexokinase video here we have a
hydrophobic interaction this
phenylalanine is interacting with both
valine and leucine residues and these
distances of about 4 angstroms measured
from each atom's nucleus
are fairly representative of hydrophobic
interactions involving atoms of this
size perhaps a better way to view the
interaction is to change to a
space-filling rendering notice how close
the surfaces of the amino acids are here
they actually appear to touch these
hydrophobic side chains cluster together
in interactions that exclude water from
that area of the enzyme moving over here
we have a hydrogen bond the implied
hydrogen atom on this o H group of the
threonine sidechain is hydrogen bonding
to the carbonyl oxygen of this glutamine
residue hydrogen bonding is stronger
than hydrophobic interactions notice the
distance between the nuclei is shorter
this one being 2.8 angstroms
finally let's look at a potential I on
ik interaction aspartate is negatively
charged at biological pH and lysine side
chains typically gain a proton in the
body becoming positively charged before
we examine the active site of PGI in
detail we need to look at the reaction
mechanism this isomerization reaction
actually looks a little extreme how on
earth are we going from a six membered
ring to a five membered ring well the
reaction doesn't actually occur on the
closed form of the sugar first the
enzyme opens the ring a proton is
removed from the O H group on the
animerica Arbonne using a basic enzyme
residue the opening is facilitated by a
protonated amino acid within the active
site that donates a proton to this
oxygen atom as the ring opens since the
reaction occurs on the open chain let's
compare those of glucose and fructose
now instead of looking like a drastic
rearrangement of the carbon skeleton we
can see the carbonyl group has simply
moved one carbon atom over the
isomerization step begins when the
enzyme removes a hydrogen atom from the
carbon next to the carbonyl carbon of
the aldehyde this forms an enol a very
common intermediate and biochemical
reactions this intermediate is actually
called an IND I'll because there's an
alkene here and two alcohol groups in
dial to complete the reaction a basic
enzyme residue deprotonates this alcohol
and the electrons left behind form a
carbonyl this time a ketone and the
alkene gets protonated by the enzyme on
the other side the sugar ring can again
close before the product is released
from the active site there are several
crystal structures of Rabbitt PGI that
give us some insights into how the
active site residues catalyze the
chemical reaction the overall structure
of the human and rabbit form of this
enzyme is very similar and the active
site amino acids are totally conserved
in fact even the active site a bacterial
PGI contains identical amino acids to
the human form in this structure the
crystallographers captured PDI bound to
the cyclic form of fructose 6-phosphate
in gluconeogenesis this is the substrate
of the reaction so to begin the ring
must first be opened being a basic amino
acid histidine can become protonated
this histidine here is very close within
hydrogen bonding range of the Ring
oxygen so this is likely the proton
donor the active site is a special
environment and depending on the amino
acids and substrates nearby many basic
and acidic amino acid residues can
switched from being protonated
deprotonated to promote catalysis the
crystallographers that solved this
crystal structure proposed that this
lysine instead of being formally
positively charged is hydrogen bonding
to the hydrogen atom on this water
molecule this allows the water to behave
more like hydroxide and be a better base
since its other hydrogen atom is tied up
with a lysine the lysine nitrogen
deprotonates this water becoming
formally positively charged while the
oxygen atom of the water deprotonates
the hydrogen atom on this o h group of
the sugar this allows the ring to open
up with the help of the histidine
residue we looked at just a moment ago
here is the open chain form of glucose
6-phosphate notice the aldehyde and the
phosphate group here there's a compound
quite similar to this called six phospho
glucan ik acid or 6pg they both contain
six carbon atoms a phosphate group and a
carbonyl group the big difference is
that 6pg contains a carboxylic acid
which is negatively charged at
biological pH instead of the aldehyde
that glucose has the carboxylic acid
group prevents the compound from forming
a ring and can give us more information
about how the PGI enzyme may interact
with a linear substrate
fortunately 6pg is an inhibitor of PGI
and there's a crystal structure
available for us to look at examining
the active site with 6pg bound we can
see this glutamate residue which is the
basic amino acid that deprotonates the
open chain hexose sugar to form the in
dial intermediate once it does that the
now protonated glutamic acid side chain
can move over and donate the proton back
to the other side of the alkyne you see
although crystals
furs can give us great static images of
the active site proteins are dynamic
shifting and moving to interact with
other molecules though we're focusing on
catalysis here we need to remember that
all of the amino acid residues in the
active site are critical in determining
the substrates that the enzyme will bind
here are some of the important hydrogen
bonding interactions that form with the
inhibitor 6pg and these certainly
contribute to binding the open chain
sugar substrates as well notice that
many of the hydrogen bonds involve water
mediated contacts protein crystals are
not dry hard crystals they must contain
significant water to maintain a
biologically relevant shape since you
and I and the rabbit this protein comes
from are mostly made up of water if you
enjoy diving into this enzyme with me
please like this video subscribe to my
channel and we'll look at more
macromolecules together in the new year